j'ai beaucoup réfléchi et je me suis dit
que ce serait formidable que je puisse
choisir les deux alors ça
malheureusement
c'est impossible un marc vous savez et
s'ils ont pratiqué la polygamie
oui mais malheureusement cet interdit en
france oui mais alors pourquoi on
appelle ça la polynésie française où on
appelle ça la polynésie française c'est
une collectivité d'outre-mer et ça n'a
rien à voir ici on appelait cette
collectivité
elle ne répondra pas et si on lui
mettait l'une derrière l'autre comme ça
et quand on est devant on croit qu'il ya
une personne 2 non c'est impossible
normal c'est combien sa marque sont
alors non marque ce soir marque c'est
votre dernière soirée dans la villa avec
les deux finalistes pour cette dernière
soirée vous allez devoir écrire une
lettre à anne et une lettre à marina des
lettres à coeur ouvert dans lesquelles
vous pourrez leur dire tout ce que vous
avez au fond du coeur marque ce soir
vous avez une lourde décision à prendre
je vous propose de rentrer dans la vie
qui ne vous appartient pas je vous le
rappelle oui je sais